non-minimalists
how do i stop searching for the thing
it's like your black shirts i want to
find my black shirts for all things but
the time spent searching is a huge time
consumer and overwhelming to my already
busy life
when i do find an item i like i feel
inclined to purchase multiples so i can
save time and energy in the future
nothing wrong with that i mean here's
the thing you're telling yourself
there's something wrong with it because
now if you're over consuming
but we have a rule in the minimalist
rule book the just for win rule
you do not buy your toilet paper one
square at a time you buy multiples now
you buy what is appropriate that might
mean a pack of four toilet paper if you
have space for 12
rolls of toilet paper then then you do
that but also the question then is like
what is the most appropriate maybe i
want the eco-friendly one or maybe i
really value the softness of charmin or
whatever whatever you're then buying
what is appropriate for you you've made
the decision so you don't have to keep
making the decision and going through
decision fatigue
and so
the reason i mentioned the black shirts
earlier because i knew this question
would come up but my black shirts even
changed over time the brand i used to
wear save khaki
i still like but their materials have
changed slightly and i just last time i
went to replace my shirts with them i
was like oh i don't like this as much as
as the way it used to feel yeah now it
could be they upgraded to some new
trendy you know make it look trendy in a
way but i just didn't like the way that
it fit me and so
your preferences might change over time
jenna and so uh yes the black shirts
when i as soon as i find something then
it's mine for a while i don't need it to
be trendy i don't need it to be
um appreciably different and it's not
about the constant search minimalism
what it helps us do
minimalism helps us
find the thing
make the decision on it intentionally
and as soon as we make that deliberate
decision we don't have to keep making
that decision over and over and over
because we found the thing that's not
going to complete us but it's going to
add value to our lives and as long as i
need that thing in my life then i can
have it if i stop getting value from it
i can let it go yeah i mean i would
offer a different perspective on the
black shirts like the the brand of shirt
that i have now it is you know it fits
my preferences the most but it's just
one of many brands out there that will
fit my preferences i just so happens i
found this one and if that company
spontaneously combusted i wouldn't be
like oh no
i'll never find another perfect black
t-shirt like i know there's something
else out there to replace it so i would
offer that person instead of looking at
the black shirt as you guys have found
the perfect black shirts for yourself
it's like okay maybe but it's just one
of the many perfect solutions for our
black t-shirts and that's a really
important point there is no the thing
right as i just mentioned the brand i
used to use before is no longer the
thing for me because they made some sort
of change yeah and at first i did feel
the twinge of oh no but it was more like
oh no now i have to figure out where
else to get a shirt from right
and and so
trying it out until you find that thing
that's how you make an intentional
decision you might try this oh that
doesn't work you might try that that
doesn't work you try something else that
doesn't work but as soon as you make the
decision
now you can stop making the decision
going forward for as long as it
continues to add value to your life
imagine if we had this attitude if we
had jenna's attitude with our our
partners
i mean uh there are what seven billion
people in the world almost eight nine
yeah okay so they're they're and like
fifty percent of them are women yes so
we're talking four billion people it's
like if i found mariah and i'm like okay
she's like great
you know we get along uh everything's
wonderful
but there are still another
you know rounding up still another four
billion women i have to go and and
you know sort through
um ryan tried that throughout his 20s
he made it to about 1 billion
rounding up to the nearest billion
but i mean the the the thing is is like
you when you come across something that
fits your life great yeah and minimalism
i think helps you appreciate that thing
that fits into your life that's right
without trying to
have every single option because you
will get decision fatigue and you'll end
up where jenna is where like you never
feel content because you're always
thinking something else is out there but
something out there is is better here's
the thing nothing is perfect you're
never going to find the perfect thing
period these black t-shirts aren't
perfect they're just they're they're the
best for the options that i have um
also there's always going to be
something out there that is just as good
or maybe even better
so there's there's like a whole like
fear of missing out thing that's
happening too with this
where yeah you're missing out on a lot
of things yes you can either uh accept
that or you could beat yourself up over
it but yeah again i think minimalism
helps you accept it helps you identify
what is enough yeah and it's not through
the more
it's not through getting
the right t-shirt getting the right
couch whatever it's like okay eventually
i'm going to need a couch because of
these reasons i don't need needed it's a
non-essential item right but it adds
value and so yes i want a couch
and so i'm going to spend more time up
front finding the couch so as soon as i
have that couch now i'm not worrying
about it anymore i know what is enough
for me now recognizing that sometimes
enough once you figure out what enough
is for you as an adult it does change
slightly especially if your family
expands or something like that but it's
still within the same ballpark so you're
enough enough might expand a little bit
and contract for certain seasons of life
but identifying what is enough is where
you start because otherwise if you don't
know what enough is what are you going
to look for you're going to keep looking
for the thing you're going to look for
the thing because you don't realize that
you already have more than enough and
the way you get to enough isn't through
acquiring the thing it's letting go of
many of the things that are in the way
yeah enough isn't enough until you
decide it's enough amen
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free